it was by a learned scholar of that time
they even Senna and I said look this man
he had put the dots together and he was
expecting a messenger like they were to
come and he had came and he was looking
at his life and everything fit except
one thing that he had read in the Torah
talking about the forbearance that this
messenger would have so he wanted to
test the prophet muhammad
sallallahoalyhiwasallam so I'm telling
my kids this that we're extracting
guidance we have a blueprint for how we
need to live our lives that's a blessing
and he had found that the Muslims were
in desperation they needed some money so
he put up he said look I'm gonna give
you alone for one year he came back
after three months grabbed the Messenger
of Allah by his neck started to insult
him can you imagine someone put their
hands on you go back home but I was born
here you Baba Bibi Bibi what do we do
what are you about to do standing in
front of the Muskies with gun we're
going to snap unfortunately you have
some Muslims getting out of line getting
ghetto that doesn't help the Dawa look
at the forbearance of the messenger
salallahu alayhi wasalam amazing the
guy's got his hands on him Ahmad brother
Aloha he's got he's like let me get him
so he insults him you guys you don't pay
your dad he's doing he's setting it up
look he promised a year came back after
three months he wants to test him so the
Prophet SAW son says go pay him and give
him some more could you frighten him you
should you should advise him in a nice
way all month
Sofer
scaring him give him more make a long
story short he ends up paying it back
the man says do you know who I am ask
you know mine he said no why do I do
snap like Jackie in this way to the
messenger of allah i was testing him it
was just one thing i had connected the
dots and I saw that indeed this was a
messenger but there was one thing
holding me back it was this thing that I
needed to test his forbearance and
forbearance means when you're in a
position that someone's oppressing you
someone's bringing harm upon you and
you're able to punish them back like the
Prophet SAW so you could have just said
go get him right now it's finished done
but he didn't and the man after that he
accept this is a learned man of that
Jewish scholar this isn't it wasn't a
layman and he accepted Islam take that
to the streets we have to be forbearing
to a whole nother level because there's
a lot of heat coming on people they
don't understand the beauty of Islam the
message of Islam and they'd fallen
victim to the Islamophobia machine so
forbearance remember this patience sorry
I was planning to actually start my
lecture with this but I think he already
spoiled it Eddie
he's always out of everyone how many of
you guys know that Eddie is actually a
qualified martial artist anyone know
that you guys just learned that I'll
tell you one thing because I rolled up a
my Sparta thing he's a teacher of mine
not only is he a mixed martial artist
but he's actually one of the best I've
ever met in my life if this guy wanted
to hurt someone he can literally
probably snap every joint in your body
before you can even say ouch I'm not
exaggerating I turned at him for three
four years and this is as knee training
in competitions and I've seen other
great fighters fight with him he's
fought with so he's trained under the
founders of Brazilian jiu-jitsu so many
Muslim people from the community don't
know but he is a national gem like
people from across
country they they take pride in studying
and training and sparring with of I've
seen UFC fighters who have actually
taken time from their career to come and
train with Eddie as a Brazilian
jiu-jitsu instructor so if any of you
guys are ever interested in learning
Eddie and sub and that's what amazes me
a lot that's one thing I enjoy a lot
about him is because where he had a
career and he still does he still trains
he has I think three four gyms across
the city where people from all over the
country come all over the city are with
him yes hundreds of Fighters in Chicago
that train underneath him
not Muslim but everyone from all fields
I fought with in his gym at with police
officers with fire fighters with federal
agents they all come there and they
train there so one thing cool that I
like about him is that where he
mashallah is so successful in his in his
art and as a master in it he's so
passionate about his Deen about his
religion and I think that's beautiful
where he excels in one he takes his a
belief system and it takes his what make
will make simple very proud and what
makes him feel very great when I when I
was training at his gym I remember that
one on wall it said something I don't
remember the exact words of it but it
was some saying that he had on the main
wall it was it was involved and I read
the thing and I was like oh my god
that's a hadith right there right but he
had on the wall there on the main wall
there was something written there
regarding anger I'm not sure what it was
and it was about it was a statement of
the purpose of Allah holiday we'll saw
them and that it shows us how when
you're doing dollar or when you have
something that you're passionate about
you can always use that as a platform to
convey your word to others so with that
I just wanted to step into the the
session that I have it had this
phenomenon Rehema hamdulillah al
hamdulillah he woke a phenomenon Azadi
he let me know Slava ho Sultan Allah say
you devil city of Awesome lmv Holly Hill
Ischia was fabulously Emma Bach
earlier today I had a session and I kind
of used that session to go up another
session that I had yesterday and another
Masjid and all these talks are kind of
linked together with the same theme the
importance of the prophet salallahu
alayhi wasalam in our life what is the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him mean
to us what does it mean to love him why
do we love him why is loving him so in
important and I asked myself this
question quite regularly now why do I
need to love this man who lived 1,400
years ago and why is his life so
relevant and so important to my time how
did his life make me a better citizen
how does his life make me a better son
how do I become a better teacher by
studying his life there could be there
are millions of people who passed before
us billions of people that have passed
before us why him and I then turned to
the Quran which is the book that we read
in the revelation of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala and in there I find God
Almighty Allah so much as saying that
you will find your best example in the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
follow him you will be guided
whoever has obeyed him has obeyed God
Almighty Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala
himself and you know I'll give you one
example a few years back I had a spinal
injury which ended my time with Eddie it
was just an injury that I had so after
that injury I went through a lot of pain
I ended up going through surgery after
that I was still in a lot of pain and
actually I'm in a lot of pain as I'm
talking to you right now and I had this
constant you know the phase of this
being heard and being injured and being
an excruciating amount of pain doctors
are giving me a medicine that I'm not
interested in looking at let alone
taking it and I kept asking myself you
know this there's this balance that
every human being is trying to figure
out the talents of pain and difficulty
we face of human beings in relation to
the mercy of allah subhan and what's out
of the mercy of God Almighty how does it
settle in with my life and I gave it
some thought
difficulty and trials are a part of our
life these are things that we actually
can never ignore they'll always be with
us no matter what phase in life you're
in right now there will be difficulty
that will follow you there I was born in
Elizabethtown Kentucky and the public
school that I went to they weren't too
many people of color there I was one of
the few people maybe five six of us
altogether so when I went to
kindergarten I remember some of the kids
there they mock made any fun of me I had
to
myself in school teacher asking what's
your name and I said Hussein and one of
the kids in the back of the class said
he's not Hussein he's insane and
everyone started laughing ha ha ha and I
was like and so mean why would that guy
say that to me and then lo and behold I
was called insane for the rest of the
year
everyone say hey insane get over here
hey insane go do this hey in the same go
to that so I thought to myself you know
what life's didn't get better when I get
to first grade I'm just telling you
that's what I thought
ok I get the first grade and I realized
that I don't get to sit in the back of
the bus until I get to fifth grade I get
to fifth grade not going to middle
school life's not getting better I
thought you know it when I get to high
school life will get better when I get
to high school life doesn't get better I
now it's all about getting into college
when I get to college now you have these
loans that you have to start wearing to
pay off and as soon as you graduate
college now it's about getting a job you
get a job every uncle and auntie in the
community is asking you there's a shoddy
career when you're getting married and
it's kind of like mind your own business
please I'll figure that out when I'm
ready but leave me alone and then when
you're married and everyone asks you
let's go hey Lydia when are you having a
boy or you're having a girl you're like
no no boy no girl and trying to figure
out life when you have your child then
you got to throw out a home then you got
to get a car then you got to go to Siena
or Odyssey and after you figure out
which one you're going to do then you
got to buy a house and you start paying
off that house you have to start
preparing for a college fund and then
you start preparing for your business
and once you pay off one house the
second house and third house you guys
know the drill and up one comes in your
life where you ask yourself when is my
life's going to be peaceful when it is
all just going to end and then you tell
yourself you know what my life is going
to get peaceful when I retire then you
realize by the time you retire half of
the limbs on your body aren't working
anymore and I respect it over this and I
came to a solution I came to not a
solution I came to this understanding
that our messenger muhammad sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam taught us this lesson
for 300 years ago he taught us a lesson
which is a duniya mother not some
alcohol that the world is actually the
field for you to put your seeds in the
ground but you will not see the fruit in
this world you'll find your foot in the
hereafter this world of the struggle is
a constant struggle there's some
struggle or the other
sometimes your struggle is emotional
other times the financial sometimes it's
physical at times its intellectual but
there's always a constant struggle that
goes on and on and on and I think to
myself that as a Muslim shouldn't I be
the one who actually never goes through
any problems I mean I believe I that I I
believe in allah subhanaw taala God I
believe in His Messenger I really put on
I'm regular in my prayer hopefully so my
desire is that I mean I tell myself that
I shouldn't be the one who faces
difficulty it should be the one who
doesn't obey God he should be the one
whose life is miserable not mine but
then Allah then I turn back to the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
he actually says the exact opposite the
Prophet Muhammad is talking to me 1400
years ago and he's telling me that out
of all of the creation those who are
most beloved to God are the ones who are
tested most by Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala
and out of all of the people the
prophets were most beloved to Allah so
they were tested by Allah Subhanahu WA
thought of the most and then after that
the people who follow them the people
who follows and the people who follow
and I sat there in my house there was a
time after the surgery where I wasn't
able to move at all I was just bound to
a chair it was exactly a year ago I had
my surgery on December 23rd almost a
year ago
so two years ago actually in 2014 so I
was standing on the chair and my doctor
told me not to move from there not to
move around too much unless I had family
members that would help me so I sat
there and I thought and thought and
thought is there a time in the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon his life where he
went through difficulty where he went
through a situation where it felt like
the world was crumbling down where a
person feels hopeless because we feel
like that at times sometimes our
challenges and life's become so great
that we don't know how to deal with them
we're not sure how to look at them in
the face and say I'm not afraid of you
because they're there in our heart
they're really bothering this we have
this facade the space in front of us in
front of the people where we show how
tough and strong we are and how emotions
don't faze us but inside we know our
weakness so I'm thinking to myself was
there a time in the prophets life where
he was really going through a lot and if
there was a time in his life where he
was emotionally struggling struggling
how did he deal with it because I want
to know I'm really struggling right now
myself and then I went back and I found
one incident
prophets life where he was struggling a
lot he was struggling so much in the
people of the community his towns and
they came and they said to him the
reason why you're struggling is because
God is because God hates you and this is
a common language that we use in our
community and someone struggling rather
than saying everything will be okay they
were beloved by God well we end up
saying it stuff like your Lord hates you
your Creator hates you that's why you're
going through this there was a lady who
came to me who told me that she was
expecting a child and the doctor said
that her child will be born with severe
disabilities when the child was born the
child had disabilities people in the
community came and told her that she was
being punished by God that's why she had
this child this is the language we use
because in our mind the image of our
Creator is of a devil unfortunately we
think that God is constantly angering
wants to punish and how God is waiting
to throw us into an infernal that is
eternal
when on the other hand when you open the
put on yep that that's not the primary
description of a loss of Hana Hana the
primary description of allah subhanho wa
taala
is one that is merciful your Lord loves
you more than your mother could ever
dream of loving you all the love that
your mother can express and she can give
to you your Lord loves you 99 more fold
than that you know your Lord is our last
man the most merciful your Lord is
ar-rahim the ever merciful you will
always be there for you his mercy will
not only engulf you in the world but
also in the hereafter and there are so
many examples where the Quran says what
ultimately was the osculation the God
says my mercy encompasses all any person
who believes in Me will find my mercy
any person who follows this deed will
find and I'm not saying that the
punishment doesn't exist I'm not
ignoring that but that's not that's not
the primary introduction of who allah
subhanahu wa taala is now punishment is
there and it's a reality we find look
what I'm talking about
Hara dies and it also talks about the
fire of health but it always mentions
paradise
it focuses on Jenna it focuses on the
prize
that's what allah subhanho wa taala
constantly reminds us of so what I'm
thinking about this I ask myself what
happened so the Prophet was going
through this very tough part of his life
the community people came and they said
yo Lord hates you your Lord
angry on you he's abandoned you when a
marriage break when a marriage breaks on
our community this is the first thing
people say they were cursed when a
business fails the first thing they say
that person was cursed when someone has
some sort of a mental disability or some
psychological conflict or problem
they're dealing with the first thing
everyone says there's a jinn there
they're cursed well we don't understand
the value of a natural difficulty that a
human being faces and we as Muslims
don't view them as curses rather we view
that as a blessing and this is where the
prophets biography really helps you out
this is where knowing who the Prophet
Muhammad Muhammad was just as brother
Eddie was saying a moment ago that we
live at a time where you know people
they don't understand our religion they
don't know what Islam is you have people
sitting on Fox News commentating and
telling us who Robert Muhammad peace be
upon and was when they've never read a
Muslim biography of it you know the only
read critique of him they've only read
the story of him that action was written
by people who never liked him in the
first place why don't you read a
critique of his from a Muslim why don't
you read his life from a Muslims
perspective you want to know what the
Prophet Muhammad loves come and talk to
me let me tell you who you love actually
scrap the talk let me show you we you
watch you know he was the person that
smiled he was a lovable person his
family loved him two [ __ ] showed him
love them to bits for those of you who
think that the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him was an abusive man I swear by
God
you can never provide me with a single
case a single scenario in his entire
life where he ever raised his hand on
any of his family members even once is
that true or false is that an
exaggeration not an exaggeration this is
an academic claim by the way I instruct
at a seminary I'm an instructor at a
seminary I keeps on an academic level
this is actually a factual claim this is
not true it's not possible all these
claims that the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him was out there to murder
everyone that wasn't a Muslim absolutely
false
think about this he lived in a city
called Medina
before he arrived here all non-muslim
when he comes there a fraction of
society except Islam and the other
fraction remains as non-muslims until he
passes away and even after that so I
asked you a question if Muslims were
supposed to annihilate everyone on the
face of this earth for what
there was only one of two possibilities
that would remain in his City either
everyone would be Muslim and forced into
Islam or there would be non-muslims and
all the Muslims would have been killed
simple yes/no simple logic right but 10
years later what happens